[Music]
google compute engine enables you to
deploy updates to virtual machine
instances in managed instance groups
using two different methods one rolling
update incrementally deploys updates in
all the vms of the mig 2. can
redeployment deploys updates to subset
of vms in the mig this enables you to
taste the update on some vms before the
update is deployed on all the vms in
this video we will focus on how to
perform rolling update to imig
mijs support two types of update modes
first automatic or proactive in this
mode you can roll out new configurations
to all or to a subset of the instances
automatically in imig here are some
advantages of proactive mode no manual
intervention is required you can
automate rollouts partially with
reactive mode which allows you to
perform testing similar to canary update
here is a quick tip
choose automatic mode when you want to
deploy a critical update across
instances immediately second selective
or opportunistic you can manually start
the update on selected instances or when
a new instance are created now some
advantages of selective mode you will
have a better control on the timing and
the sequence of the update
and here's some tip for you choose
selective mode when you want to perform
a pre-planned update during a
maintenance period so that the impacts
such as performance degradation or
downtime can be avoided for you
now let's look at how to perform a
rolling update in proactive mode in your
google cloud console
go to compute engine
and instance groups
in our project there are two instance
groups rolling update proactive mode
rolling update opportunistic mode each
of these migs have three instances other
than that we also have two templates
which we use to create and update the
migs
application version v1 this is the
current version deployed application
version v2 this is the new version we
want to upgrade the vms in rmig
select the mig that you want to update
in this example we will update rolling
update proactive mode mig
click update vms
under new template click the drop down
list
to select the new template to update to
we will select application version v2
under update configuration expand the
selection menu select automatic as the
update type to trigger proactive mode
with proactive mode you can control the
disruption level during rolling update
by selecting the appropriate value from
the drop down list in action allowed to
update vms
with each option there are different
instance properties which will be
updated select the option that works for
your requirement
we will select replace which replaces
the current instances with new instance
next one is maximum search it indicates
the number of vms that you want to
create above the target size before
deleting the old instances note the
additional instances will temporarily
run at the same time as the instances it
replaces
setting up a higher value for maximum
search can improve the speed of the
update however it will incur cost for
the additional instances created
max unavailable it indicates the number
of instances taken offline or
unavailable during the update time note
max unavailable value can cause downtime
on our mig if the value is close or
equal to the number of instances in the
mig the default value for max search and
max 7 available is one for zonal mig and
3 for regional mig let's proceed with
the default value of 1 for max search
and max unavailable
next in advanced configuration we have
minimum wait time this value sets the
length of time to wait between two
successive instance updates
alright we are all set now click on
update vms
we can open the instance group in
another window to view the instances
being stopped
and getting replaced by the new
instances with the updated application
version
all right let's now look at how to apply
selective update
in our project select the mig rolling
update opportunistic mode
select update vms
under new template select application
version v2 select the option of
selective mode under update
configuration
select
done
click update vms
now click on the instance group select
one of the instance and proceed for
deletion
there you go we can see that a new vm
has spawned up as a part of the mig with
the new version of the application
note that because we have chosen
selective mode the other two vms will
not be updated automatically
check out the documentation to learn
more about the proactive and selective
modes in rolling update
[Music]